not in shape he doesn't run he plays the
game strictly on Talent he's not like he
never runs on The Fast Break he he he's
kind of like jogging on offense and
defense he somebody has got to get a
hold of him cuz he got so much talent he
gonna be he's gonna be somewhat
successful because he could he could be
special he could be special but see I
don't know if he has a Moses Malone who
told me I was fat and lazy yeah like he
owns that organization already
but if he could get in shape this team
you would not want to play this team
because because the Shaq talking about
those others those others man are really
good no doubt but but it's G to come
down to Zion and he needs to get in
shape we had a Sprint count so me and CH
are just watching saying how many times
he actually Sprints and we still stuck
at one like actually sprinted the floor
like on different plays like